young met the Vietnamese prime minister
on the sidelines of the asean summit on
Sunday U.S President Joe Biden will be
in Hanoi for high-level talks as a
two-country Vie for Vietnam's support
this is an invitation that came from the
Vietnamese leadership
that they feel that a visit in person by
Biden to Vietnam is necessary to
announce an upgrade in the partnership
between the U.S and Vietnam
this will be the first time that
President Biden whose generation was
engulfed by the Vietnam War sets foot in
the country he didn't protest against
the war nor did he serve
I am who I am
I'm not big on flak jackets and tie-dye
shirts and you know that's not me now he
wants to elevate the U.S Vietnam
partnership from former enemies to an
important Alliance
what we've seen now is especially on the
bilateral and trade trade and investment
side we're seeing New Heights last year
we saw that the U.S was Vietnam's
largest export market and on the other
side Vietnam was the US's eighth largest
trade partner the US is also looking to
shore up its allies in a region where
China is expanding its influence to
accommodate its military Ambitions and
shift the balance of power in Southeast
Asia in its favor
in July the Vietnamese prime minister
visited Beijing for the first time
during his time in office Biden's first
trip to Vietnam is considered a
strategic step to shift the geopolitical
landscape overall what it's doing is
looking to enhance its ability to move
its assets around as needed as part of
its wider strategic deterrence effort
which is directed at China
that includes pushing back against
China's expansive claims in the South
China Sea which Vietnam resolutely
rejects while the U.S says it doesn't
take sides in territorial disputes this
will no doubt be an issue on the table
in Hanoi on Sunday Sarah Clark Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera